when year later it's still very good hey
everyone how's it going hope y'all are
doing well today believe it or not is
the one-year anniversary of a day in the
life of a software engineer and the
one-year anniversary of me starting on
YouTube
ah it's wild to think that it's been a
year it feels like it's been two months
it feels like it's been five years it
also feels like it's been one year all
at the same time and this year really
just flew by so I wanted to take a
moment and talk about kind of what this
last year has been and like what it's
been like I guess I have some special
announcements for the end too actually
so be sure to stick around for that man
I've been on YouTube for a whole year I
honestly didn't think that it was gonna
last this long I thought that maybe it
would be like a 1 to 3 month thing
because I'm really bad at keeping
hobbies and sticking with it but it's
been one of the best years of my life
for some context I started my youtube
channel
last year July of 2018 and the reason
for why I started has a couple of
reasons number one I was at a point in
my career as a software engineer where I
wanted to have a bigger impact on people
around me and basically helping people
to become a part of the tech industry
secondly I went to VidCon last year for
the first time ever with work and Jarvis
and I having both been just huge YouTube
fans for a long time we were kind of
fangirling the whole time we're like
this is amazing we went to a bunch of
sessions to just get some empathy for
the creators that we are creating
software for but what we found were
lessons and pieces of advice that helped
us to basically get the motivation to
start our channels so basically my want
to do something big and really influence
the world positively especially in the
world that I'm immediately in and my
love for YouTube kind of just came
together at that moment and so a day in
the life of a software engineer was the
very first video that I made and it's
been just wild
it currently has 2.6 million
views which how like how how does that
happen
honestly a lot of it is things to y'all
y'all have watched it or you washed it
shared it and that really helped it to
get basically picked up at a YouTube
algorithm and get millions of views I
remember when I posted it I shared it
with like my Facebook friends and almost
like hey you can watch it that would be
really cool I made a thing honestly one
of the coolest things this last year has
been seeing all the different versions
of a day in the life of a software
engineer seeing people do it in
different cities at different companies
in different roles and every time I see
a new one I get really excited and I
legit like watch all of them other than
that I've learned just a lot in the last
year of being on YouTube I am someone
who does not have any sort of film or
production background so I've learned a
lot about writing and editing it's it's
it's a whole thing to be a youtuber and
I've learned a lot of that I still have
a lot to learn but I am in a much better
place than I was a year ago where I made
my first video on my iPhone 7 using
iMovie and one of my favorite parts of
having been on YouTube for the last year
is that I met so many cool people having
connected with people that I wouldn't
have connected with before or in other
ways and talking about our interests and
love for YouTube basically and also what
we want to do by making videos and just
kind of what our passions are but yeah
honestly that has been such a gift and
that is one of my favorite parts
actually my favorite part about being on
YouTube the other thing I learned after
being on YouTube for the last year is
that I've learned a lot about myself
I joke with people that being on YouTube
has kind of been almost like a form of
therapy for me which is very true
because you see when I was thinking
about like who I am what kind of brand
do I want to have what message do I want
to put out into the world it forced me
to look inside myself and be like okay
well like who are you what are your
values what's important to you what do
you know how to do what do you not know
how to do and I've continually done that
every step in the last year sometimes
feelings so hard like I didn't post the
video November and other times just
succeeding very well and just feeling
very happy about the results it's been
an interesting year because of that
and I definitely would have been a
completely different person honestly if
I hadn't done YouTube and at the end of
the day a lot of the credit goes to you
all you all for watching my videos for
commenting sharing subscribing I
honestly would not be here if it wasn't
for y'all like there's a lot of things
that have happened in the last year that
were thanks to everyone watching and
every single person who has commented
every single person who has messaged me
and said that they feel a little bit
more inspired to do computer science to
just taste their life passions literally
it just kind of kills me inside like in
the best way and I really really want to
thank you at the end of the day I'm just
a girl behind a camera spewing her
thoughts dumping her brain on the
internet and a lot of the strength that
you all have comes from within so thank
you all for sharing that with me and
thank you all for having me be a part of
your journey I would love to know what
you all have thought this last year has
been let me know like when you started
watching my videos and what you like
about them I love hearing people's
stories and I think it's so incredible
that we're all connected through this
way so yeah let me know in the comments
down below send me an Instagram message
send me a Twitter message I genuinely
want to hear from y'all which honestly
has been kind of one of the hardest
parts actually I really appreciate
everyone who has written in so far but
I've had some difficulty just connecting
with people and lots of people at once
I don't think YouTube is super conducive
to that and either in Instagram and
Twitter are okay but this actually leads
into my very first announcement so I
finally have a patreon page which I say
finally because if y'all know me I work
at patreon and I should probably have a
patreon page by now so the reason I want
to have a patreon page is twofold number
one I want to dog food some of the stuff
that me and my team are working on and
really understand what patreon is like
to creators the second one is I really
do want to connect more with more of you
all and I think that patreon is a great
way to build that via a membership
service so I am launching a membership
service essentially so for anywhere from
$1 to more a month then you'll get
access to a bunch of benefits that I
will make exclusive to patreon this also
means that we'll just be able to talk a
lot more I will post
just some thoughts and stuff and more
comments I think it's going to be fun
because it almost be like my safe
sandbox for me to test out ideas and
talk with y'all and interact with you
all in a in just a smaller amount so
there's going to be a lot of cool
benefits one of which is exclusive
content like Bluebird reels and extra
content which I know y'all love and I'll
also be using the lens lenses the
feature that me and my team worked on
for about a year year and a half and I'm
excited to finally use it to interact
with y'all but it's basically like
Instagram stories or snapchat quick
15-second videos that are exclusive just
to my patrons and so I'll be using on
that a ton will also have a benefit
where we will have a private Google
hangout session monthly for folks in a
specific tier which I know that I was
going to do monthly live rooms here on
this channel but honestly they got a
little bit intense and frantic for me
and not so fun anymore
so I'm excited to do this on a smaller
scale on patreon and one of the last
benefits which I'm really really excited
about is I'm launching a series just on
patreon where I'm going to be watching
my old videos and commenting on them so
it's kind of like an editor's cut you'll
kind of get a look at what I think about
when I'm watching these videos what I
thought about wow is making them and
just kind of commentary of you know just
lots of self-deprecating humor so I
actually made the first one which is
nothing less than the editors cut to a
day in the life of a software engineer
so that is on my patreon page right now
so I'm very very excited to be launching
this patreon you can go check it out at
patreon.com slash my you go and pledge
to any tier that you feel comfortable
doing so there's a lot of different
benefits that come with the different
tiers and so I'm really excited to have
you on there cool if you have any
questions or anything like that feel
free to leave a comment down below or
message me or what-have-you
awesome ok so I guess I should just move
on to the second announcement which is I
have a peel box I got one honestly like
just for fun so send me fan mail and the
p.o box address will be in the
description box below cool so I think
that's it again I wanted to say thank
you so much especially to those who have
been
from the very beginning and I hope that
you will stay around for a little bit
longer and yeah thank you so much for
having me one you on YouTube like while
have to think about but I'm very excited
to be here and yeah it's been really
great so thank you all
I guess I'll see you next video bye ha
burn might done a little bit yeah it's
very hot it's just freshly brewed so me